welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is new knowned Montero assistant
professor of political science at Yale
University professor Montero's main
research interests are in international
relations theory and security studies
today we'll talk with him about his
forthcoming book that addresses three
questions related to the topic of
unipolarity is it peaceful is it durable
and how does it impact deterrence
welcome professor Montero thank you
pleasure to meet you let's begin with a
definition of unipolarity what is it
so unipolarity is a world system in
which there's only one great power so
it's different from other world systems
in that in the past we've only had
systems with two great powers say during
the Cold War in which you have the US
and the Soviet Union or before the Cold
War more than two three four five great
powers in Europe the u.s. rising in the
early 20th century and since the end of
the Cold War in my thinking there's only
one great power because the u.s. has far
more power than any other state of
course this is mostly a definitional
question depends how you define a great
power and some people most people will
define a great power as a state that's
able to defend itself from any other
state from even the most powerful state
in the system I think that's not the
most useful way of looking at it because
if you look at it that way you get a
world in which today there's seven eight
nine great powers arguably today any
state that has nuclear weapons can
defend itself and so you'd end up saying
that North Korea is a great power the
same way that the u.s. is a great power
I look at it from the perspective of how
much power states can project and the
USS ability to project power in the
global scale is much greater than any
other States so I think about the u.s.
is the sole great power we have today
and the unipolar system is a world an
international system with one great
power okay very good
how did you come to write the book what
was your inspiration um started in
graduate school so I did my PhD at the
University of Chicago and I was working
on international security topics
looking for answer tation topic and I
was struck by two things one well first
of all it's for me it was the most
important topic I could think of in the
sense that you know polarity is the way
the world works today so it's the way
the international system works today
it's if you want the background
condition on which states make their
decisions and looking at what had been
written on the topic a great deal has
been written on the topic I'm by no
means the first one to touch it I was
dissatisfied with how the literature
just focused on great power interactions
and so basically the summary of the
literature I could find was well we had
two great powers during the Cold War one
is gone the Soviet Union therefore
there's only one therefore it's peaceful
there can't be conflict because there's
only one and of course this is right
it's also I believe quite trivial and so
I started to look into interactions
between the one great power we have the
United States and other states and the
second point that that got me very
interested in this was that since the
typical view that you get published on
the topic is that you know polarity is
indeed peaceful I was struck by the fact
that the US has been involved in a great
deal of war since the end of the Cold
War so the u.s. in the first 200 years
of existence in which it was one among
several great powers was it worked for
35 years in the last 20 years since in
the Cold War it has been at war for 12
so more than half and it struck me that
there was a lot of room for improving
our understanding of the dynamics for
that generate conflict in worlds in
which there's no other great power how
did you do the research for your book
I'm still doing it it's it's mostly
research on the theoretical aspects of
it so first of all because I don't
believe we have empirical evidence to
prove a theory right or wrong we only
have 20 years of you know polarity we
haven't had any system like this before
we had great hegemonic powers in the
past like Rome Imperial Rome but they
worked in ways that were very different
we didn't have a state system so they
had an imperial dimension that we don't
have today and so it's it's a rather
unique situation and the the empirical
evidence we
is scant we have 20 years of evidence I
don't think with that you can prove any
theory right or wrong and so I thought
the burden was on the theoretical
development and sometimes people tell me
well if you can't prove the theory right
or wrong so why is it that you're
devoting yourself to the topic and I'd
go back and say that is the most
important topic I can see today in in
international affairs and so I started
by looking at the theories that exist
out there that could help us deal with
with this system that we have today with
figuring out how the world works with
only one great power and I didn't find
much about interactions between that
great power and other states so I
started to explore that and also with a
great deal of attention to the question
of nuclear proliferation because I think
that nuclear weapons make a great deal
of difference in terms of states being
able to defend themselves without
necessarily acquiring the same power say
the US has so states today can sort of
defend themselves in a relatively
cheaper way by acquiring the nuclear
arsenal without developing all the
conventional power that the US has so I
started to look at in terms of the
question of peace which was the first
one I tried to address how different the
world is today in terms of smaller
powers not having a potential security
sponsor okay so it's a very different
world from say the Cold War in which if
a state felt threatened by the US
it could very likely find a sponsor in
the Soviet Union patron and Alliance
supporter these days that option is not
there and so by definition they can't
seize there's only one great power they
can't find another great power to sort
of prevent an attack or a threat from
this great power and therefore I think
that there's a great incentive for them
to acquire the capabilities the military
capabilities namely nuclear weapons that
would guarantee their security and
survival ok and why is it important to
look at you know polarity especially in
terms of the three questions you put
forth
so the topic is important I think
because not only it's the way the world
works today it will be the way the world
will work as far as the eye can see so
we will live in a unipolar world
probably for my lifetime at least four
three four decades hopefully my lifetime
is longer but at least four three four
that gets more and so it's imperative
that those of us who study international
politics actually devote themselves to
studying the dynamics that will take
place in these next few decades many
people today think that the u.s. is in
decline
you have successive waves of what I call
decline is literature in the eighties
there was the fury of Japan rising today
there's the the idea that China will
rise and take over and so I think that
it's recalled of Niels Bohr the
prominent physicist saying that
prediction is a very difficult business
particularly about the future I can't
really predict whether China is going to
rise or not but I think whether China
rises economically is not necessary it's
not there's will not necessarily lead to
China rising militarily it depends on
how we deal with them so I think it's
important because we may despite the
rise of states that are growing faster
because they are at a sort of earlier
stage in their development like China
India Brazil
perhaps Russia will recover who knows
despite that we will still have a long
period in which we will live now in
terms of the three questions I asked
them do you just ask me back I think
those are peace and durability are the
most important questions you can ask so
if you believe that the system is
peaceful you want the system to be
durable if you believe the system is not
peaceful you don't want the system to be
durable so they're interrelated and
those the answers of the answer to those
two questions depends the amount of
conflict and the costs and benefits that
actually being a unipolar power being
the number one power in the world by a
very great different difference like the
u.s. is today the benefits and the costs
of that so whether in fact it's a good
thing that the u.s. is number one
and how much conflict can we expect as a
result of that situation and then I look
at the smaller question of deterrence
the narrower question of deterrence
because deterrence is is a literature
that emerged in the Cold War and it's a
technical term but basically mean means
how do States get to go to war so if
there is a crisis between two states
what has to happen for that crisis to
actually result in military conflict and
so it's sort of the as we call it the
micro foundations for answering the
other two questions so the micro answer
for the other two questions that's why
it okay and what are some of the
conclusions you reach in your book so
first conclusion which is about the
first question is that any polarity is
not peaceful so I don't necessarily
disagree with the conventional wisdom
that it is peaceful in what concerns
conflict about great powers because of
course there's only one so by definition
it's going to be peaceful I do disagree
however in that it is peaceful overall
because I think the effect of a unipolar
structure of the international system on
the interactions between the great power
of the US and minor powers may result in
a level of conflict that will compensate
in a negative way that absence of great
power war now it's very difficult to
give more precise answers in terms of
how many casualties can you expect how
big will those conflicts go the war is
very unpredictable so once you get into
conflict I I bracket that question but
it's likely that we will have
significant confident levels of conflict
the other aspect the other question is
the question of durability which is a
question on which there is great debate
will it be durable will the u.s. be
forever the only great power will it be
the only great power only for a while is
it an age and then China or India or
whoever it is takes over or is it
actually a moment that's already
finishing because of these days the
financial crisis you know there's always
a temptation of sort of finding the news
of the day and turning them into an
argument for us decline I think that
question has two answers and the witcha
to focus is on the first the people tend
to look at
economic growth and of course since the
u.s. is not the most populous country in
the world as other countries catch up in
terms of economic development their
economy will be larger and it's very
likely that the US will not be the
largest economy in the world three four
five several decades ahead but I think
the rich term which is the second step
which is well will that economic power
rising economic power that other country
necessarily convert that economic power
into military power and compete with the
US and try to for instance deny the u.s.
the current command it has over globally
air sea space the u.s. currently has
control of what we call the comments
everything that's not another state is
controlled by the US and it has around a
thousand military installations abroad
would a rising China try to revert that
situation and I think that the answer to
that is it depends is the answer to many
questions is depends on the actions of
the u.s. it depends it's very much in
the u.s. is own hands to have a policy
of accommodation and reconciliation that
enables the rising power to actually
feel satisfied with the system to
extract from the system the benefits it
fuels it is entitled to as a result of
its rising power or whether the US will
try to contain a rising power and
therefore increase its dissatisfaction
with the way the system works and as a
result lead it to actually convert its
latent power economic power into
military power and try to compete with
the u.s. so I think that depends very
much on how the US will behave in the
next few decades okay final question and
you've touched on that a little bit but
how does your theory of unipolarity
differ from conventional wisdom today
three points first I would say I try to
argue that as I said the new clarity
will be the way the world will work for
a long time whereas I think the
consensus today not the consensus but
the growing trend in the literature is
to find reasons for u.s. decline be it
the financial crisis
that somehow will affect the u.s. more
than it affects other countries be it's
military over extension the fact that
we're fighting a number of conflicts all
over the world through conflicts and
that we are overextended those conflicts
are not going particularly well at least
Afghanistan and our military budgets and
all of that are overstretched to a very
old older and significant argument by
Paul Kennedy my colleague here that says
you know great powers tend to overextend
and therefore the Cline
the growing consensus is on that
position I would say that that's not
necessarily the case that you could see
the same preoccupation with the rising
Soviet Union in the 50s and 60s you
could see the same preoccupation with
the rising of Japan in the 80s huge
literature saying we're doomed they're
gonna overtake us in five years allows
they didn't grow in the 90s or in the
past decade very little growth so that
question I think is I'm more inclined to
say we will have unipolarity for a
longer time and most people believe and
I would also differ on the question of
peace as I said not because people are
wrong but because they're not looking at
what I think they should look at which
is the same dynamics between the US and
countries like Iran or Korea arguably
those will be smaller conflicts than a
world war will be or a war with Russia
World War three with the Soviet Russia
but they can still be important
conflicts and those are mechanisms for
conflict that are directly derived from
the fact that the world is unipolar so
unipolarity per se doesn't cause any war
but it creates the background conditions
that facilitate that promote certain
mechanisms that can leave to war and to
those mechanisms that I've developed my
attention in terms of the durability
question the last one and perhaps the
most important I think my take differs
in that I separate the economic growth
aspect of it from the military growth
and if perhaps we can look at the
economic growth aspect of in terms of
other powers rising and eventually
overtaking the US
economic size power I think that's a
separate question from the military
power question and I try to
differentiate between both and argue
that in a nuclear age a state can
guarantee its security and survival by
acquiring nuclear weapons without
necessarily matching the u.s. power and
that in fact if once it has acquired
nuclear weapons it's priced to continue
to acquire power to the point at which
it competes with the US it's actually
taking actions that are detrimental to
its survival and security because of the
presence of nuclear weapons so I think
those are the main differences I see
thank you very much for being here with
us today sharing some of your research
for more information about professor
Montero and his work please visit our
website at yale.edu backslash macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you